conservation of birds is a unique
challenge how do you study an animal
that spends most of its time hundreds of
feet in the air sometimes you just need
to catch one got him just lust in his
eyes right now I'm Wes Larson a wildlife
biologist and lover of the outdoors for
as long as I can remember I'm traveling
the country to find the next generation
of conservationists the people on the
front lines of the fight to understand
our planet and protect the animals we
share it with
[Music]
today I'm headed into the desert due
west of Salt Lake City I'm on my way to
a remote research station in the go
shoot mountains of Nevada I can just
barely start to see the go shoots out
there in the distance so remote in fact
the researchers spend months at a time
on site you have to be an especially
hardcore conservationist to sign up for
this job
hey man you're wet must be Jesse yeah me
too
here in Sioux smocks I am Jesse Watson
is a research biologist with hawk watch
this is the second season on the
mountain but he's been working with
birds since he was a kid this is a
long-term Raptor monitoring site we've
been counting and catching Hawks here
since the early 80s so about 35 years
we're gonna hike all the way up to 9,000
feet yeah man all the way to the top
there are no roads to the camp supplies
are flown in by helicopter carried up on
your back starts getting fairly fairly
steep in this next session lot of
switchbacks but it's worth it for these
birds Raptors are kind of a barometer
for the ecosystem they're at the top of
the food chain and so if they're not
doing well then there's an indication
that something is wrong the hawk watch
researchers live full-time on the
mountain
counting Hawks by day and sleeping in
tents at night welcome to camp and
where's the hot tub for hawk watch to
study these birds up close they have to
catch them first
and here's where an unexpected member of
the team comes into play so Raptors are
migrating along the ridge they're hungry
so we use pigeons as part of our team to
help us capture them and I notice he's
got these harnesses for your pigeons
just to make sure that you know the hot
comes in it's not actually gonna hurt it
absolutely I mean they're pretty
critical member of our team and we
definitely treat the ones in utmost
respect with our pigeon safely in place
we settle into the trapping blind and
meet Scott one of hawk watch's veteran
crew leaders so how we doing Scott how's
the flight get it really good it's
actually pushing our biggest day there's
a lot of birds thrown up out there and
before we knew it you're just wondering
what's going on right now huh so yeah
we've been in this blind like I don't
know five minutes we already caught a
Cooper's hawk catching the birds doesn't
hurt them in any way okay sweetie there
you go McCann I see you're being very
delicate with those talons yeah so the
thing you really got to watch with
Raptors is their their feet and their
bill are the two things that can really
tear you up and in just a couple of
minutes each bird is given a checkup
and a tracking band she's banded she's
been you got jewelry it's so crazy to me
how it calmed she is she's in this
little tube like she's not chirping
she's not yep struggling this pulley
relaxed so those are the main body
measurements weight wing cord and
standard tail yeah
the go shoot mountains are a kind of
superhighway for migrating Raptors and
over just a couple of hours we banded
seven different birds overall at this
site Hawk watched researchers have
assessed and banded over 65,000
different Raptors yeah so the next step
is basically releasing her so this one's
ready to go we banded her
she is definitely ready just the way
they like look at you it's just so
intent like it's like--there's looking
straight through you almost you ready hi
[Music]
she goes pretty cool I bet you don't get
powder that no never gets old yeah
definitely not there she is right there
while catching and banding is crucial
for assessing individual birds the
status of Raptor populations is what
jesse cares about most so the bulk of
the team's work looks like this during
migration season in the fall the
researchers are out here every single
day literally counting each bird that
flies by through the years they've
counted over 13 million one by one you
want to kind of start below horizon and
just gonna scan up slowly and if I see a
bird I just yell it out yeah counting
Birds can be tedious
it means watching the skies for hours so
what's that one down there oh yeah yeah
yeah that's an adult red tail so what's
got a bird down here just going down low
the county in itself is the most
important thing number two year after
year after year we can get those trends
so we can see like hey these numbers are
going up or they're going down we've
seen declines in species like Golden
Eagles and American kestrels on
migration through these counts the idea
that I'm getting is that if you guys
like weren't up here on this Ridge in
the cold in the wind for months at a
time all day long counting these birds
like no one would really have any idea
what the numbers are doing absolutely
that's a real dedicated effort you
really have to commend our crews that
are counting and doing the work
when you work in conservation you
sometimes forget that when people see
the studies they don't see the hard work
meticulous data collection and luck that
you need to get the results standing on
this mountain seeing Hawk watch's
efforts firsthand is a great reminder of
the real tangible work that goes into
this kind of conservation
you